Most of the remainder of this particular lesson is going to be concerned
with architectural styles. As with buildings, software systems come in,
in, of different types. Okay, we call those types architectural styles. Taylor's
definition of an architectural style is a named collection of decisions.
Those decisions are appropriate in a particular circumstances that is
dependent upon you know, the system specifications and its major concerns.
The design decisions constrain, what are the possible components and
interactions and by using. The architectural style.
You get various benefits from it
on the ultimate system you're you're building and the process of building it.